with me to discuss the latest military
developments on the ground in Ukraine
Major General Neil Sexton a defense
consultant for Universal defense and
Security Solutions Major General great
to see you again let's start by
discussing uh those missile attacks on
leviv that we've been learning more
about during the course of today why
would Russia be attacking somewhere so
far west so far away from their other
key objectives at the moment well I
think there are two main reasons why
Putin would want to hit over in the West
End of Eve the first one is that of
course the Viva is the town where a lot
of NATO equipment has been flowing into
into Ukraine and moving to the east to
reinforce Ukrainian fighters in the East
it's also a place where there are
facilities that are repairing military
vehicles and it is a center that has
been considered quite safe for training
and so on in addition though you have to
say that Putin is deliberately trying to
terrorize the civilian population we've
seen over the last few days that the
number of people flowing back into Levy
from Poland and other countries has
increased and people felt that it was a
safe place to evacuate from from the
east of the country across to the west
and to come back in that now must have
been undermined by these attacks Let's
uh do the reverse trip with our maps and
dive into the Easter in particular in
the South where of course there's been
much talk about renewed Russian
offensive there do we think it begins in
Earnest this week well difficult to tell
the exact timing General Alexander
devonikov the new Commander there will
be massing his forces for a coordinated
attack and the coordination between air
artillery and the ground movements which
has previously been lacking around Kiev
as we've seen over the last 53 days that
will be important for him as he attempts
in this region of Donetsk and Lou Hanks
to achieve some sort of a link up
potentially linking up here around the
western side of Genesis far down south
as mariopol so uh he's got some
difficult challenges ahead not least the
defensive systems put in place by the
ukrainians over the last eight years in
that region
um very detailed defense static and with
maneuver capability and also the weather
is not good for maneuver off-road at
this time of year are there lessons to
take from Mario pole for for the rest of
this Eastern region that Russia is going
to be focusing on I mean and what why
has it taken the Russians so long to
finally defeat Mary Paul in full well of
course it hasn't yet won in mariopol we
still have a couple of thousand
Ukrainian Defenders valiantly holding
out and of course some of the tactics
used by the Russians the indiscriminate
bombardment of the destruction of
Civilian infrastructure and indeed the
infrastructure around the still works
here that has all helped the Defenders
it is much more difficult to attack a
city that has been almost destroyed than
it is one that still has access roads
and own and inside the still works
you're on three levels there's
underground bunkers and tunnels there's
infrastructure still above ground and
then all of the rubble that's around as
well a very difficult place to attack
and to actually get those last couple of
thousand determined ukrainians out of
there and general Neil Sexton thanks so
much